come on
the next 15 minutes could change your
life forever 1.34 billion dollar ticket
every year tens of millions of Americans
spend their money on these lottery
tickets I always imagine them as like
these cool colorful things this is just
like a receipt with a barcode these
things are usually at a gas station or a
grocery store and typically you get it
from like a guy behind a counter or from
one of these cool flashy machines they
cost anywhere from a few cents to like a
hundred bucks and as more and more
people buy tickets all of that money
goes into one big pot the jackpot and it
grows and it grows and sometimes can
rack up to like two billion dollars that
much money
third Mega Millions drawing to break a
billion dollars 1.3 billion 1.9 billion
2.04 billion and even though everyone
buying tickets presumably wants to win
the jackpot at the end of the day after
all the ping pong balls and the numbers
and the weird game show looking things
only one person actually does 1.9
billion dollars I can't believe it then
it can be yours for Just Two Bucks
[Music]
meanwhile everyone else is left just a
little poorer Phoebe you don't have any
of the first five numbers this is the
lottery it is a government-sponsored
gambling game that is surprisingly human
like we've been doing this for thousands
of years and we will probably continue
to do it for thousands more and not just
like in the United States all over the
world and it's almost always the
government who's running the lottery
okay so like a little harmless fun that
helps the government make a little extra
money it's not a big deal right no these
are not small numbers this is not a
little anything in 2021 Americans spent
over 100 billion dollars on lotteries
100 billion that's with a B these are
giant numbers this is something we
should look into okay so let's dive into
this why do we do lotteries and why is
the government running these things and
what do they use the money for and I
guess most importantly is this even
ethical
1.35 billion dollars
[Music]
what would you do with a lot of money
foreign
hey pause real quick I need to thank
today's sponsor who is betterhelp thank
you better help for sponsoring today's
video I'm a big believer in therapy I've
been in therapy for several years now
and it has reshaped my life in very real
ways and what better help is is a
platform that makes therapy accessible
to people it's kind of hard to find a
therapist like in the traditional way
where you're sort of like calling around
and seeing like who's in network and
stuff with better help you literally
just sign up you take a quick quiz and
it matches you with a therapist in their
giant network of like tens of thousands
of therapists it's not bound by your
physical location so like you can get
access to a therapist that works for you
that fits your specific needs you can
talk to them you can chat with them you
can video call with them however you
want better help use this technology to
make the therapy process much easier and
it's quite affordable there's no
insurance involved there's financial aid
for those who need it and perhaps most
notably you can change therapists at any
point for no cost there's a link in my
description it's betterhelp.com Johnny
Harris clicking that link helps support
this channel but it also gets you 10 off
your first month of better help so you
can try it out and see if it helps you
we are in an era of destigmatizing
therapy as like something that we
actually all need and I'm grateful that
better help is making it more accessible
to people so link for that deal is in
the description thank you better help
for sponsoring this video let's get back
to the lottery
record-shattering one point
one point billion dollar ticket I can
feel the winning ticket
I'm fairly certain this is the winning
ticket humans are big on gambling we've
been doing this for thousands of years
40 million five hundred thousand
one of the first versions of a lottery
was over in China it's rumored that they
actually used the lottery to fund some
of the Great Wall of China oh and after
they like chose the numbers the results
are said to have been delivered by
carrier pigeon the Romans the Dutch and
a bunch of other governments over time
and throughout the entire world have
done lotteries to usually fund big
projects that the government wanted to
do in England they also loved lotteries
and the settlers who wanted to come here
to the new world used lotteries to help
fund their trip eventually the monarch
of England was like whoa guys wait a
second don't use your extra money to
fund lotteries that make you leave us
use your money over here taxes were kind
of a sensitive topic for England but
anyway the colonists were like all right
bet
bet like bet you know like bet like that
[Music]
I'm not in touch I'm not in touch so
they don't do lotteries for like 100
years but then eventually they tried to
do a lottery to like fund their Ward
against England to become like free from
England so yeah lotteries are not new
they've been used for a long time and
governments have always run the blah
blah but in the past few decades
lotteries have turned into something
much bigger and more and more they've
begun to Target a certain kind of person
let's
let's go see if I can win the lottery
[Music]
spent two US dollars on a lottery ticket
let's see what happens the jackpot for
this one is 20 million bucks
seems like a pretty good deal there's
this one Lottery called the Mega
Millions it's where a bunch of States
put all of their lotteries together into
one giant Lottery which means way more
people which also means a way higher
jackpot which then attracts more people
and then it's just like the greatest
thing in the world for the lottery okay
wait but why does the government run a
gambling scheme that incentivizes people
to like spend their money on gambling
we'll get there in a second just hold on
but for now I just need to Revel in what
is happening in my brain right now this
very human feeling of buying a two
dollar ticket so low risk I didn't have
to pay that much but the potential of 20
million dollars the Mega Million Lottery
is making me realize why gambling is so
enticing and for such a simple little
game with mega million you choose six
numbers the first one having to be
between 1 and 70 and the last one having
to be between 1 and 25 no idea how they
calculated those rules but whatever okay
you choose your numbers you can also
just tell them to choose the numbers in
an algorithm will do it for you which is
like listen I already have an algorithm
sort of running my life most the time if
I'm in a gamble I'm gonna choose the
numbers myself I will heat it there
anyway eventually a bunch of balls go
into this little spinny thing and they
choose the numbers and if they choose my
numbers
I win 20 million dollars so at two bucks
a ticket we can infer that probably
millions of Americans just did this they
went out and bought a ticket like this
with hopes of changing their lives oh
and this isn't like once a year or
something this is twice a week so
hopefully be drawing my numbers tomorrow
night and I will be watching anyway
let's get back to the explanation I got
a special Advantage about marrying it
not for me no no I think I had numbers
might come up so here in the US you've
got a bunch of these big Mega
multi-state lotteries and they're all
run actually by the same non-profit
organization but then you also have
these
you've got these little just instant
winners like like I could scratch this
off right now and see if I win 10
chances to win we have to do this right
now where's a penny no seriously we got
it we got to do this up to five thousand
bucks
wait a minute this has to be a joke
what does that say
no way
oh no you might have to get like three
of them yeah oh reveal a oh see ya
I don't know how to gamble I was like I
just won a thousand dollars 19 24.
come on oh man the rush is so real
womp womp that's so sad I was so ready
to win today okay sorry I'm getting out
of my like um intoxicated Buzz of
gambling which clearly I haven't done
enough I grew up Mormon okay give me a
break you scratch off this latex you see
if you won you don't win I didn't win
it's actually really satisfying but it's
kind of messy you also have smaller
lotteries that are usually more frequent
but they're smaller jackpots but you
have better odds anyway the point is
there are all sorts of lotteries
speaking of odds what are my odds of
winning the big jackpot according to one
statistician who crunched all the
numbers my odds for winning on this
ticket is like one in 302 million which
like let's be honest no one really knows
what that means I don't know what that
means what is that 302 million that's a
bigger number than my brain can fathom
so let's do a visualization imagine you
have 66 bathtubs I mean I'm not sure why
you need 66 bathtubs it seems a little
bit excessive but
who am I to judge and yes I know a lot
of you know this I cut my hair that's
because I couldn't handle not shampooing
my long hair okay let's just get it out
of the way I know everyone's been
thinking it anyway you've got these 66
bathtubs and each of them is filled to
the brim with rice 4.5 million grains of
rice in fact how did we calculate that
number go to the sources we actually did
an analysis to see how many grains of
rice would fit into these bathtubs 4.5
million so you've got 66 bathtubs and
they're all full of rice and one of
those grains of rice is painted gold now
close your eyes walk through the field
and thrust your hand into one of these
66 bathtubs and pick out a grain of rice
and maybe you found the golden grain but
yeah those are my odds of winning
tomorrow night not as fun to think of it
like that and this works even if you buy
a ton of tickets or use the same numbers
over and over again none of this really
does anything meaningful to change your
odds Mr Beast did this great video a
while back where he bought a million
dollars worth of scratch off tickets and
lost about 300 000. okay so we're done
with this part of the video the lottery
exists it's big you'll probably lose we
all know that my bigger question here is
why does the government have a monopoly
on this gambling game
[Music]
I just so happens
you have to leave it with me and I'll
look after it for you you can come visit
it anytime you want to some economists
argue that gambling is this natural
thing that humans love to do so if
they're going to do it anyway why not
use that as a game to generate revenue
for the government but to me that begs
the question of like what do they
actually use the money for luckily
there's data for that and for an example
let's use this giant Lottery called the
Powerball and let's make the numbers
easier let's just say that everyone has
bought tickets and the big pot has
totaled up to 100 million dollars it's
just like you know actually in the
ballpark of something that could happen
half of that money goes to fund the
jackpot so let's just say that 40
million dollars is for the jackpot and
the remaining 10 million goes to all the
smaller prices okay but under the hood
something else is going on if you look
at all the Billboards for the Powerball
at this moment it will actually
advertise it as 67 million dollars for a
reason that I will explain in a second
but the point is that only 50 of all the
money generated goes to the people who
bought the tickets so the question is
where does that other 50 million dollars
go well six percent of that hundred
million dollars goes to all of the gas
stations and convenience stores and like
other businesses who sell the tickets
they get in on some of this nine percent
of the hundred million dollars so like
nine million bucks goes to pay all the
people and expenses associated with like
running the lottery like all the
advertising and like the employees and
stuff these are private companies that
contract with the government to run and
advertise the lottery that leaves us
with 35 million dollars of our original
100 million which according to
powerball's website goes to quote good
causes supported by the lotteries womp
womp what does that mean what are good
causes the Powerball website won't tell
you much but we did Research into this
and we found that from state to state
the definition of good causes changes in
a lot of States this money goes to quote
education like in Virginia in 2022 where
the lottery money was used to fund
almost 700 80 million dollars of the
public education budget this is good
leveraging humans obsession with
gambling to like fund the education of
our children I'm super into it
oh Until you realize that yes they give
all this money to the education but then
they reduce the existing budget so that
it ends up basically being the same
number which means the lottery doesn't
actually give any extra money to the
education system that is so stupid Oh
and the money isn't even distributed in
an equitable way the funding a lot of
time goes towards scholarships colleges
and ends up benefiting wealthier schools
so yeah that's what they mean by
education kind of deceptive not cool but
then there's other places where the
lottery pays for things that we take for
granted that probably never would cross
your mind like in Colorado where the
state spent 14 million dollars on their
parks and wildlife in 2019 using profits
from the lottery or Nebraska where they
use the money to fund like their state
fair we could have guessed oh and this
is a good one in Minnesota they've spent
over 51 million dollars of Lottery
profits to fund organizations that help
people who are addicted to gambling like
what like reusing the lottery money to
help people not Gamble I don't know that
means just that one's a weird one to me
okay so governments used Lottery money
to do government things build
infrastructure fund public programs and
stuff like that cool okay wait but why
does the government have to collect
money in this weird way
we'll get to that I promise but in a sec
I know everyone's wondering about what
happens to the winner
[Music]
these Lucky Ducks who just walked into
tens of millions of dollars like how
much am I going to get tomorrow night
when my numbers are picked
sort of manifesting
in our little scenario remember that
they had advertised 67 million dollars
and that really it was 40 million
dollars that was allocated to the winner
how does that all work out that is
because when you win the jackpot you can
get it in two different ways you can get
it all at once or you can get it slowly
over the course of 29 years if you get
the cash all at once then the government
immediately takes out 24 of federal
taxes and then of course the state will
get their taxes so like here in DC it's
like 9.75 that's taken off so even
though you were advertised 67 million
dollars the actual jackpot was the 40
million so really you walk away with
about 26 million bucks the reason it was
advertised as 67 million dollars is
because of the other option if you take
it slowly over the course of 29 years
then the government holds on to that
money and invests it in like bonds and
it gains interests and they project that
over that time it will actually be a
total payout of 67 million dollars that
also gets taxed a bunch of ways and
whatever and eventually you end up with
about 43 million dollars if you do the
overtime so 26 million versus 43 million
dollars depending on if you take it all
at once or take it over time the point
is that once again even with the winner
the government makes a lot of money off
of lotteries and this is the number that
should blow all of our minds the U.S
federal and local Lottery Revenue in
2020 was around 27 billion dollars 27
billion dollars in government revenue
because of the lottery and this is kind
of where it feels a little messed up
because I thought we already had a way
of funding the government isn't that
just called taxes
wow you think we should get that over 20
years or go for the big payout hello
America I'm John Crow it is Tuesday
January 7th okay 20 million dollars
[Music]
a millionaire ah I already lost this
back to the video so now we can answer
this question why does the government
run a gambling scheme and it boils down
to this lotteries were illegal in the
United States for a very long time
public opinion was very against them but
then in the 60s New Hampshire needed
money at the time they didn't have a
sales tax or an income tax they were
running low on tax revenue to fund their
schools so they passed a law that
allowed them to start a sweepstakes to
raise funds for their schools and it
kind of worked they made money I mean
presumably right like and then other
states were like wait a minute we can
make taxes into a fun game and no one
will get mad at us and the answer is yes
you can it's called the lottery and so a
bunch of other states started to adopt
it and now we're headed into an era that
is characterized by lower and lower
taxes by lowering everyone's tax rates
all the way up the income scale each of
us will have a greater incentive to
climb higher to excel to help America
grow taxes have never been popular but
this was a time when taxes really
started to hit a new low so after years
of being illegal the lottery is back and
it is back with a vengeance soon you
have these multi-state National
Lotteries and the government starts to
make millions and then billions of
dollars of tax revenue revenue that they
weren't getting from just boring old
taxes okay so the lottery is just
another tax but who ends up paying these
fund voluntary taxes the people who pay
them are the ones who don't really have
the means to poorer and less educated
people are the ones who play the lottery
most the lottery is mostly a tax on
people who don't know math the lottery
ends up as a tax on those who can least
afford it it's a tax on the poor but
most of that money is spent by
low-income consumers in South Carolina
one report found that people who make
less than thirty five thousand dollars a
year spent more than double on lottery
tickets than people who make over a
hundred thousand dollars a year let that
sink in for a second
double they also found that people of
color are more likely to buy lottery
tickets than white players one study
found that in almost every state whether
it's by Design or not neighborhoods that
have Lottery retailers have a higher
poverty rate than neighborhoods that
don't have Lottery retailers remember
this is the free market these retailers
are following the demand so yeah you
start to see a picture of the government
using the desperation of those who are
less educated to generate Revenue that
they don't get from boring old regular
taxes and then I think the moment that
actually gets me here is that that money
that Revenue goes to fun things that
isn't often beneficial to the poorer
communities that bought the tickets and
paid the taxes
so yeah that is the lottery the question
is why do we keep doing this and again
it goes back to that very shrewd
economic argument humans love gambling
they're gonna do it anyway why not just
regulate it and make some extra Revenue
out of it but as always there's some
private interest here too keeping this
all alive who prints all of these right
who makes the latex that goes on the
little scratch off those are companies
that make a lot of money off the lottery
and they actually have lobbyists keeping
the lottery alive so yeah the lottery
exists and will probably always exist I
mean humans love gambling and taxes
exist and are necessary we need to fund
our government
but do we need to run a gambling scheme
to raise those taxes the specific way
that the government runs the lottery
today is a regressive tax on the poor it
raises money and it sends that money to
places that doesn't benefit the people
who are funding that tax and so when we
see that gambling funds education or
goes to good causes to me that just
feels misleading we just need to call it
what it is
the lottery is a tax on the poor
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right another video is in the hopper
the lottery what is Hopper not cool
thanks for watching everyone
um I want to tell you about a few things
that I need to tell you about at the end
of the video that you may be interested
in number one it's no longer just me I
mean it hasn't been for like years but
like we now have a large team of people
who contribute to making these videos
and we have a behind the scenes Vlog
that we publish once a month over at The
Newsroom The Newsroom is just the fancy
way of saying patreon but Newsroom just
sounds way cooler so we call it The
Newsroom every month we publish a behind
the scenes Vlog we have my scripts are
over there you can read the scripts and
see what those look like if you're
interested you get a royalty-free Tom
Fox song and you get the warm fuzzy
feeling of supporting this Channel and
the journalism that we're trying to do
the link is in my description you can go
check that out
um another way to support that might be
helpful to you is like we have Luts and
presets Luts are how we color our video
without a Lut it looks like this with a
lot it looks like this much better we
developed these Luts with a professional
colorist and they're really pretty you
can buy those and help support the
channel and also color your photos and
video much better you can go watch my
next video like right now like it's
actually live
um over on nebula because we publish
everything a week early on nebula ad
free so go to nebula using the link in
my description if you use the link in my
description it actually helps support
the channel so like do that if none of
those things are interesting to you and
you're still watching this I have to ask
you why are you still watching this like
why are you still here when you could be
watching some other cool video on the
internet
to answer in the comments see you later
interactivity of like oh why am I
still here